what is going on everybody welcome to
the eleventh tutorial in our matplotlib
tutorial video series here well what
we're gonna be talking about in this
video is handling for unix time so there
are all kinds of ways that you might get
date stamps and all that we've spent a
lot of time on the conversion there but
it's because there's so many I can't
just show like every version of a date
stamp but I do think it's important to
at least show also how to convert from a
UNIX timestamp to the matplotlib kind of
format so coming over to our Yahoo
Finance API like I was saying before if
you use a term like in these large
numbers you know you're gonna get these
like kind of date stamp but if like
let's say we do 10 D for 10 days you'll
see that things have changed
significantly and now no longer do we
have this you know year-month-day
situation we've got these numbers like
this is like 1.4 billion
what's that well these are UNIX
timestamps so again the unix time is
just the number of seconds after january
1st 1970 so now we have to convert that
to a date time that is acceptable format
plot lib so the way that we're going to
do that is we're going to just use
another little simple function it'll
actually be a little easier than the
previous one we wrote because there's
some handling for it already
UNIX timestamps like I was saying before
are really popular so it's really
popular with the computers so people
have handled the UNIX timestamps for a
long time so coming over here to our
grant error file what we want to do now
is at the top let's go ahead and import
date time as DT generally you import
date time as DT and then sometimes
people will import date time date time
as a time ok so again this is just a
standard that people do if they import
the main module it's DT so now what
we're gonna do is let's have this up so
let's pull up a command prompt here and
open Python you can do this wherever you
want or you can just watch you don't
have to follow along if you don't
want to but feel free to if you want so
first let's import date time as DT we're
also going to need to import time now
let's say first of all if you're not
familiar you can print it you know time
time and that gives you a unix time okay
so this is the current unix time so
let's say our example time equals time
time so we can print example now and
there you go you've got your time now
what we want to do is let's go well it's
print DT dot date time dot from time
stamp example okay so we print that out
and what we get is a it's a legible
timestamp
okay so 2015 the month is July day 8 or
8 so July 8th 2015 and then this is in
you know military time so two twenty two
twenty three and then you know
milliseconds basically okay so then we
want to convert that date and the way
that we're going to do that is we're
going to convert it to numpy time so
date conversion we would say is equal to
NP dot vector oh we don't have numpy
import it so it's important on pi and we
would say dates Kampf equals NP dot
vectorize DT dot date time dot from
timestamp
I thought we imported oh we just
imported numpy we didn't say as NP so
I'll just call I'll just do numpy date
comp so then we could use date Kampf and
we can convert a date stamp like this
you know to to a date time so we're
gonna take this code and we're gonna
come over here and we need to bring in
let's see we don't well we don't need
time because that was just for an
example so date time there should be all
we need actually so we'll come down here
where we've pulled the date here and
instead of converting we're actually not
going to convert anything so
well we could well we could add a
converter if we want to but yeah we're
not going to do that so we'll just do
this and we'll just convert this as a
list after the fact so we'll come down
here and then what we would say is in
fact let me just let's take this line
just because I want to save it for later
copy it paste and then highlight the
whole line and then alt 3 to comment it
out cuz we're gonna go back to using
this data but I do just like I said I
want to show you guys how to convert
unix time just in case you need it
so then delete all the way up so we'll
use this one for now but soon we'll
return back to our old format so here
what we need to do now is we need to
convert the date the date time so we'll
use date comes for date converter and
that's going to be equal to do we have
numpy yes so date calm equals NP diets
vectorize and we vectorized based on a
DT date time dot time stamp or actually
from timestamp so from time stamp from
time okay so now we're gonna say date
equals date com on the date cool
so that should do it so now instead of
using this ten-year range let's do a 10
instead of Y 10 D which we know gives us
unix time instead and we will run that I
think we're all set let's run it and see
what happens that worked out cool ok so
what we have here are the days in it
probably looks kind of funny to you
because they're connected but these are
basically you know this is where the
stock market was open I mean this is
intraday data here so we can zoom in
this is like one day of data ok so stock
market open stock market closed and then
they're just basically connect this is a
close of the market open trade close
trade close trade clothes trade close ok
so that's what's going on here
but anyway long story short it worked so
that's how you can convert unix time
stamps to matplotlib dates that's all
I'm gonna say on them I'm gonna return
back to the original 10 years
information in the next tutorial and
we're gonna get rid of this information
here but for those of you want to do
intraday data go for it
pretty soon we're gonna get off of so a
lot of people will be like I want to get
rid of these nasty lines well pretty
soon we're gonna be doing candlestick
graphs so there won't be this nasty line
connecting them so keep that in mind but
anyway I did just want to show how you
can convert from UNIX time today it's
time because it's pretty important to
know how to do it anyways so that's it
for this tutorial if you have any
questions or comments regarding this
tutorial please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video